today on our show not in the bag AXI
donor of the volume to a big fat man I
better review today I'm from another n
yeah that men on that man
[Applause]
well the fat man a Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark barnard look at us here
man we're in space what this game oh my
god some guys got blown and visas over
there and someone flipped a space
quarter because that's all it life is
worth right here in the scum and
villainy Cantina which is on and
Hollywood for how to live in Hollywood
California telomers
where dreams come true that's right
jay-z who shoots our show this is barmen
he's kept his event bar that looks
achingly familiar to something called
you go online if you go to two scum and
villainy cantina calm you pick up
tickets places open they extend it as
always suppose to be other than a little
time but being so popular they're
opening mount until the end news you're
gonna get so it's [ __ ] nuts man like
if your cosplayer
this is instagram clickbait heaven and
you got yourself a [ __ ] Mandalorian
costume you've always wanted
but normally you're taking pictures like
in your [ __ ] bathroom you know
festive hair so I like it into the
toilet this is what you want to take
your [ __ ] pictures totally cuz oh my
god it's crazy man it's clone out of my
cerebellum what's crazy is out they
haven't been shut down I'll be we're
gonna help right Mac home I know because
yesterday it's it's space neutral right
you know what I'm saying it's not like
it's suggestive but it's not yeah
nothing infringes a trademark or cop
like Captain Kirk would not be entirely
out of place in a place like this no no
there have been space bars in lots of
different pop cultural touch down that
so this is just one and this just has
over water we
so bad ass [ __ ] placemark is just
pitching on the idea of what do
weekend's for kids yeah I mean that I
would totally take my kids to a bar in
the day barn the night with the kid
becomes a questionable parental decision
but for lunch yes the lunch you
suggested tater tops
[ __ ] yeah that's just in this
environment I'll stop my head for no
good reason
blue milkshakes see ya take it out we're
gonna get taste it's not what our
basically picture did I did his idea
vision my wagon is so okay man but this
this is the place you want to hit up you
if you're anywhere near Los Angeles and
or if you're gonna if you're like you
know what I'm doing trip come on out
this is a fun cool lunch and so it's got
like the perfect place to talk about a
space movie did you hear that Segway
they sell in an artful segue normally
doesn't require someone calling
attention to it but I'm sorry I had to
just drop all through there like much
great this tell them what we talked we
were talking about Gardens Agassi you -
you and Dina - Oh a monkey once DMB one
good fine girl Vee - yes that's right
Rizal bring it's all brandy brandy by
the way like this is just to bring it
all back to me because [ __ ] as
members about brandy and Mallrats and
names for the same song Wow clerks
post-production driving around we had
this like super sound and 70s
compilation that was on there's my star
road moments I wrote bring into and so
when that started the movie
instantly I don't know instantly I fell
in love with look Marvel you take every
old-ass muffled I give a faded list the
building five minutes of the movie and
you can take all my money all his money
and he's my friend all your knocking on
Jackie's money give you his money my
kids money [ __ ] almost people's money
in cups outside I gave it due to buckle
go back out steal that [ __ ] give it to
[ __ ] Marvel films if they continue
doing that a young Daffy Kurt Russell
smile was my sake [ __ ] dude - I so
much mile don't sitting there watching
them like damn it's like they can't this
can keep going no I
you know what I'm saying I can Robert
Downey jr. I guess is one of the first
right earlier they did him in more that
and what's happening little war
yeah whatever Antony I know what Michael
Yahoo stay young him up so but you know
this is a right we get to spend a lot of
time with trip Russell later on in the
movie spoilers Kurt Russell's in it and
see the young version was really talking
will justify can hair flow in the breeze
and thanks me I think I met James Gunn
half a second once long long time ago
and stuff but I'm a big fan of swim mmm
I love Gardens galaxy it is one of the
most probably one of the most perfect
films ever movies ever made this
entertains call it whatever you [ __ ]
rule it's such a well told story so
imagine so
and the so perfect and the Seuss on of
whatever it is he burns to [ __ ] like him
the first one like you know little
asides and [ __ ] like that
one guys were Jack's like I'm keeping
this night I'm guys like this my
favorite I'm like it like that
it's just genius because that makes me
think that I James Gunn is godly one my
top 10 favorite directors later he's
been responsible for a lot under 10 I
love this movie was a tough [ __ ] bulk
like you how do you [ __ ] touch the
original I'm even get close and
everyone's set up and all the charm is
gone in terms of like the meet-cute of
it all how do you [ __ ] do a number to
that sinister or sounds doctor an action
let's all look how do you do a number
two in Sullivan because I make a number
two that son of yours how do you follow
that up it's something that like gets
close you do something that equals the
other I love it
you not a bit oh my god I love it so
much it's a moon over the moon night you
know I just rewatched one this is
morning and one is so [ __ ] special I
cried more at one as you know where
she's being here take my hand they seems
buck that's still [ __ ] chokes me up
that's that movie it's [ __ ]
perfection and this movie is damn close
perfection
[ __ ] ton of fun they don't make them
better than this like I put it in the
top ten and Marvel movies they've made
but you know look it would be tough to
touch a perfection of one it opens so
emotionally that first one and then I'll
send the [ __ ] spaceship pointing at
the kid like you just go on an insane
journey that I can only like in - when I
saw Star Wars as a kid play this is new
or maybe buckaroo mumbling - just like a
completely new world of space where you
know like this is I can't believe this
didn't exist before so it was going to
be tough to follow but for me having
just re-watched one having seen - last
night he stuck the land in a big bad way
I think he did a wonderful job they did
the visionary clearly has a vision and
has a tone and it kind of runs of all
his movies even back to the trauma
trauma stuff you know these guys I'm
just sent to humor but by all rights
that movie shouldn't be as good as it is
and for me there's a section in there
about 15 minutes that probably might
have could have benefited from editing
or whatever but I mean you talk I
wouldn't eat an egg on let's go but in
terms of storytelling at one point the
middle of the movie I was like wow we're
almost done because I look at my
watching like oh you know how we go and
then I didn't see where it was gone so
that's a sound good story that I was
like oh that's where we wind up in the
third act that's interesting I'm called
that so I I think he stuck the landing
in a big bad way and in terms of heart
it's still there's still a warm bunch
and the father thing I don't know why
you know like I connect to the moms and
where we've been God both my parents
around was growing up so I don't have
either one of those things but a sick
mom lying bed and debt it lying dying in
bed you know I'm sure Libra that you've
connected that on some shocking little
not having a dad present or going like
one over my dad was back maybe I didn't
have the quite is mm-hmm
gain emotional connection as I did to
the first one but what they and that
doesn't mean like Otto tartlets or
anything like that this movie ass [ __ ]
it's just tough to [ __ ] touch that
die monthly and when they do touch it a
little bit in this it's is achingly
wonderful when he gets when [ __ ] beer
goes when star-lord gets mad in third
but I will say this I just watched some
bolt [ __ ] the funnier movie it's
funnier
I think verse one is hysterical I just
watched impression I literally lol a lot
of funkin moments but last night I had a
[ __ ] ball do not by myself is most
fun I had by myself since I like jerked
off this morning a lot oh yes it was I
was filled with joy the whole time like
he was able to push on my butt now yeah
this stuff like you know in the first
one the Nova Corps like grabs me as a
[ __ ] ten year old in the heart and
stuff the the what they call these gold
piece of sovereign you know don't I
don't have an emotional connection to
them but you know when you spoilers oh
we're gonna spoil many many things
Stanley's can yell even [ __ ] with
just look with my web today I'm not
gonna then looked perfect
oh my god I was like I can't believe
that's where we are we're in a world
where they can throw away a reference to
the I'm giving five seconds no longer
the watchers a lot to like oh my god
that was maybe one of them that since
Darth Vader snapping on that lightsaber
and gonna eat it all way seeing the
Watchers [ __ ] talking to Stan Lee in
a spacesuit snowman like I love this to
James Gunn he's [ __ ] he's smart he's
funny good for him so happy like that
movie made me so damn happy and you know
at a certain one about halfway through
those like what yard look out say
regarding booster and then by the second
half third act and you you know they are
in the name again the summer
hand down my favorite moment of the film
and maybe one of my favorite moments in
a theater all year maybe in the last
five years is [ __ ] my Michael Rooker
as yonder with me yondu Mohawks from the
competition from my issue wanna Gardens
prototype yes oh my god seeing him like
holding the excess the the arrow his
managed Swiss Leggero can do and
descending and their exchange beautiful
gone like you look like Mary Poppins and
he goes the cool guy geared photos yeah
he's pretty cool and Michael Rooker is
skilled like my whole audience did with
us was a Los Angeles Jayden brown and
they all [ __ ] applauded like was a
premiere when Michael Walker said I'm
very calm with y'all and B phonetic holy
[ __ ] I was like one of the greatest
moments in ministry so enjoyable that
anything that [ __ ] Drax said this
time around
boy they nailed that character they know
exactly what they got their Peters story
line with with you know with his dad for
me got a little scraggy in the middle
but not to the point where I was like
I'm lost or bored or anything like even
but let me see who else
well it's going to blow I mean how
[ __ ] baby Groot is adorable and they
literally say the movies too adorable to
kill everything with the characters was
pretty damn fun sweet laying on ice it
they're gone like Batman's like a lot of
people would be my [ __ ] thing away
rocket was was wonderful Gamora and I
thought they did some nice stuff with
the more on what's your name
killing nebula nebula their storyline
that made me get all teary and stuff
like that but hopefully more for the
more next time I [ __ ] love you so
I'll watch the whole be gray out I mean
I like the character London I like that
actually
Zoe Saldana is just so then in every
as is homeboy plays Peter quill
star-lord Oh Chris Pratt idea don't you
just want to eat him up he made a man
made of charisma oh my god they [ __ ]
true movie star [ __ ] with the banya
doll [ __ ] ruined canteen you suddenly
the [ __ ] first portable shirt deal is
getting worse all the time I've blown it
a lot I'll be done but when you look
marks been suspiciously quiet and oh my
god I'm getting ready to die now I'll
not be like know where the but show up
how how can you you know I you know I'm
on your awesome story John and I will I
grant you the ability you see things I
don't so go ahead I'm not going to even
ask how you can possibly find anything
yeah I have wonderful wonderful oh my
god I will I will say this I enjoyed
myself enormous Lee at have movie
leezard it up these are characters I
want to be with and hang out with actors
I want to be with a network absolutely I
will say that it felt a bit like Lethal
Weapon 3 came at O in that be hard it
almost doesn't matter what they do I
just want to watch them do it
okay alright and they're all [ __ ] Joe
Pesci back alright Joe Pesci back many
who so yeah I would love to return me
together they're really good I like into
the Chris Rock ins man 3 the Chris Rock
of his movie in Shawn gun basically oh
good oh [ __ ] chum guns took a big leap
idler for those of us that don't watch
the Gilmore Girls be running too big
Gilmore Girls and I don't watch it
either but I know I'm from from Gartley
elegans and from his brothers but he
plays rock as well yeah I work over
sucanat just does his voice for like
[ __ ] I mean graphically goes worse
and movie but I guess I'm set he's going
down my hair what he actually put some
[ __ ] better with a little graham
bell's all over his face he [ __ ] all I
know magic I will say that like how easy
is to fool me I'm a filmmaker like what
sound good I'll get you a rocket is so
small this is why
and making the big movies is why I'm
watching the first Guardians which I
love yes like you do
ah it's fundamentally a movie about
trauma it's a movie about like Peter
quill his fundamental trauma is snatched
from her mother died never knew was dead
you know gamora's trauma is I've got a
father who I [ __ ] hate and I've got a
break away from and my sisters try and
call me back to that family rockets
trauma is they they nobody like me but
me ultimately good and ask for this yeah
like you turned me into something awful
and horrible Jackson's trauma is it's
family got killed so all of them are
smarting or hurting from this
pre-existing and to some extent current
present trauma and they come together as
a family to heal that trauma together
but that's all though this movies about
this movie seems to be about hashtag
family like hey so I'm going to find my
dad a little bit you know like it's
there's a lot of sitting around talking
about family as opposed to actively
pursuing that family or in the case of
rocket rejecting that family
subconsciously to draw them closer like
there's and it's a lot about that it's a
lot of push and pull but there are
sequences with people sitting in couches
talking about their family which is a
thing I didn't know that I wanted in a
science fiction movie with spaceships
and [ __ ] and rocket then like everybody
got Manson I suppose we got mantis sure
was incredibly fun as well yeah I mean
there's there's a lot of fun to be had
but I feel like the core of this movie
isn't as strong at the core of the first
movie who wrote this time Jim gun did it
solo zone the last time around it Nicole
Perlman UK men and right like he put a
spin on it and made it his own and you
know after you can see the James Gunn
both of them it is your what is here's
what would be my if I had to take a bone
if I had a ball musically and I don't
but the thing that was like huh I didn't
reach my not expectations but like here
we go man because we walk in one of the
one of the most fun aspects of the last
movie was every one of those tracks was
piece of my child this time around not
so much you know what I mean I'd like
wonderful soundtrack but like there was
not a lot of oh there's my jam oh
there's my jam oh right with the
exception of brandy which is perfection
and not only do they use it not only is
it open movie well and set you in a
place but when ego Kurt Russell's
character ego the Living Planet which
everybody was a weapon and again [ __ ]
school if you're watching this you know
who know the Living Planet is him
quoting Britain we'd like with you know
and using it biographical what was just
so movie and as was like when he was
talking about Peter's mom and he's your
virgin something like not Tiger water
religion like that but then he said she
knew all this all the words to all the
songs in the radio that made me glass up
like that's a beautiful [ __ ]
sentiment whoever wrote that sentiment
he's a real human being who thought that
at one point like yeah one of my
favorite aspects of this person is that
they could sing every [ __ ] lyric to
every song really [ __ ] like that you put
in enough of that you could sit on
couches and discuss man I mean that now
yeah I mean and I was I was missing a
sense of drive through the movie yeah
you know the first movie is we got to
get this [ __ ] ball inside the balls
infinity stone and that's whatever we
got to keep this out of Romans hands or
give the potatoes an office you will
happen in which to be fair like having
just rewatched it almost all of that is
like I forgot yeah I mean it's all my
god Ronan the accusers all MacGuffin II
[ __ ] it's all just like we got it
we're going to move the ball and just
keep it going
it's like it's like a charming sitcom
yeah Cheers where you [ __ ] love all
those characters but you know on tears
they crank out like 20 to 23 years so
you know if you don't like one wait a
minute there's another one coming yet
this is like as Mark said you get to
spend time with people you love and this
time this is the adventure and you know
is it as strong as the last adventure
like right like he's pointing out
there's Mia missing drive right like I
was missing them
feeling a thing or guarding Singh until
you got X equal a bull they did both
they're still a thing the very beginning
and they got a thing the very end and
then you just kind of missing a thing in
the middle where they're doing anything
but because you love these characters
you're totally down what are you gonna
do life sucks I've been dad yeah she
nebula gets way more to you and lot more
that that whole sister relationship is
kind of sweet she's fun to look at yeah
the nebula character I have like last
night in the theater grand I'm a STONER
the last night in theater and this
morning I was watching his like the
intricacy of that [ __ ] work mm-hmm
how nobody got nominated for the word
for that no I just like Groot is amazing
but it's much people in doing this [ __ ]
but nebula is old school longer than
prosthetic effect and old screen those
cool leg olds so yeah I thought I kind
of fell down the nebula I was just like
wow I mean look at that [ __ ] how long's
that [ __ ] take and then to act
through that as well that is all
clippable it real lady on line
yeah she's great children talking
looking thing like many Latinos you go
like what a great actor she called ish
yes yeah she's not she was one of the
contenders of Doctor Who and who is the
the what's her name uh mantis is also
not from this cheese from the yen
she's friend she's half Vietnamese ah
she was that character was wonderful and
that you know if they could they have
used her more true and we'll day in the
future problem so but every moment was
her interacts was magic yeah I mean the
night I look good to just that the
antennas and said I saw a photo because
the whole time I'm watching moving on
where's the sex again yeah clearly
something specific you so much what part
of it I thought maybe like a night and
there's there's bases of antenna and
then they added the desert yeah but she
was Indian eyes I met Nina stuff yeah
but she looked fantastic and sweet
character and like you know Hindle and
like you're disgusting and then like
coming around on your beautiful it was
not he was fantastic they inject a lot
oh my god and with good reason
yeah it's ISA [ __ ] crushes it and
like you know everyone go [ __ ] yourself
your
the bag to the ship in a perfect world
that didn't get an Academy Award
nomination for Best Supporting Actor on
a [ __ ] makeup until be funny earn and
beats and supportive oh I thought he was
wonderful everything came out of his
mouth [ __ ] had me rollin had me just
doing this I mean honestly the storyline
of that movie that I most found myself
gravitating towards was yondu story like
and and partially because yondu still he
gets to spoilers alert it gets to end oh
yeah you know and like the problem with
the middle sequel is that you know that
nobody's going to die you know that
nothing's going to happen to anybody
it's it's a four that was out of a huge
figure out that he was gonna kick you
know like I think I think it was when I
think it's when he gets the Finn
emotional so good I think it really good
what do you really I think it was like
me this is when did you get to kill
everybody you're like deny the only
thing I think you're cool you're down
that because they it's an amazing
[ __ ] sequence and yandi was supposed
to be a bad guy yeah and so I don't have
them I don't bump against the bad guy
doing bad guy things it's once you
realize why he's that person once you
realize the again the trauma behind what
his life was about and how that resolves
itself and hits about his Redemption and
it's about him realizing that his
actions have forced his family away and
make me [ __ ] cry you you that is the
movie right that's the movie which is
weird because that part of my problem is
that Peter quill is not that movie it's
Yonder has a best story in the theatre
has that movie last year I got a really
good as I rewatched one this morning
it's like like you know with the
exception of Wonder Woman added which is
a mystery song they gave him a perfect
Carol York to build them into what he
needs to be to the rest of the series
if it was if they elected to do a
different character on lines in like the
main [ __ ] tune like who would have
saw the yondu who was the most moving
part of the storyline if they did that
every episode or every [ __ ] movie
whether like now let's focus on this one
hmm I'll be okay yeah I mean and that
does speak to I mean we talked about a
years ago my larger theory that
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is one big
TV show and these are episodes of that
TV show that will all build towards
Swift week and Avengers movie and then
you'll keep going to episodes this felt
like the yondu episode of the guardians
of the galaxy TV show where he gets the
big heart he gets the big move she gets
the big you're gonna cry because yandi
dies and the awesome funeral scenes all
onion right side he split watches I can
smell you on that's true we all get a
spoil but yeah and then I love that bit
of it I love those shown up all that
should what nah he's really moving I
mean oh that was a tough act to follow
the first one because the first movie
has Groot we are Groot yeah that's like
you're [ __ ] dying by the ton and the
movie takes you on a real emotional
roller coaster because you get really
emotional and crying [ __ ] and then he
does the dance-off even they're like oh
my god was just [ __ ] good and the new
you know who plays Mountain actually is
pretty [ __ ] tight man with your
action I'd rather just like are legit
like like really I get roasted but and
then they take you back into emotional
territory when he sees his mom and in
this movie that's yondu gets every one
of those beats and gets to play one with
Peter gets to play one with rocket given
with a group yeah the boots on that ship
at the end good you get some the fin so
he gets a nice little so awesome thanks
played okay go get this how is that look
like a fin as a death and uh and then
you know he gives his kind of
explanation to Peter like you know the
whole he may have been your father and
we was and daddy like Rooker crush here
Rooker deserves a [ __ ] Best
Supporting Actor now I wouldn't I would
absolutely go with jung-hoon [ __ ]
fought me on Batista I've heard a little
bit on Batista alright your new top but
I guess he I would definitely get Rooker
once well yeah liking all of this is to
say again I really enjoyed going to see
this movie yeah but like here's why I
don't love
the wail of a person the first one does
all of these things so incredibly long
it's so complex to tell that story with
six main characters and half of them are
on stage and you've got to give emotion
to everybody there buddy the story
that's got a weave together duck
together by hand like space porn - just
like we're all these shifts which will
end forget about totally but yeah like
this is this there anything about this
is a really good sequel to a movie that
I love to death
I just and it was never it's hard to
name the sequel that not even meets but
surpasses how you feel about the
original there's got to be like higher
Empire Godfather time Dark Knight aliens
like Pole Terminator Terminator
you know like this you can name them I -
Hannah I don't know and you know like
terminator is an amazing [ __ ] slick
and Terminator 2 is an amazing [ __ ]
slag and it's not like and they [ __ ]
improved upon some [ __ ] oh yeah I
guess maybe it has some tough one both
of those movies are fun yeah they're so
smart both of them are really smart and
and what the second one does by adding
technology doesn't in any way invalidate
the first movie that you saw wait so do
Marvel follow-ups Marvel second is the
this better than dark world yes this is
this is their best second movie there
you go you know like it's better than
Iron Man - it's better than throw the
dark world I don't I don't want this is
definitely better I don't know if it's
better then I don't think it's better
than Winter Soldier
I think Winter Soldier there are they
good point and it's dirty but this is
more enjoyable than where soldier it
just makes you smile old time do you
have a comment so different flavor yeah
like they're there with the different
things but I think the Winter Soldier
objectively is a better movie than their
misses but yeah all of this again is to
say did not hate it in any way I'm not
[ __ ] on it anyway it's just like
here's here's where I as a viewer just
began to like bump a little bit but okay
no that's I'm having a good time I
translate will also [ __ ] loves about
the movie I mean I did like scene scene
Stallone I did like seeing the original
guardians line up at the end do you
think that we see them are they setting
up something else for us are they
setting up because again you don't cast
a shell yellow and Ving Rhames and
Stallone as little Jew averages for the
og Guardian the vision Guardians like
without some plan to do something with
them later I'm look I hope so but you
know you are talking about the film a
girl ended the last movie was like oh by
the way here's Howard you know so he
James Gunn seems to be God love this
Marvel [ __ ] as much as bad to go see the
movie so you know it felt like it that
felt more to me like a oh my god can you
imagine we have redid we're talking
around burger issue one like here's the
original lineup - yon do the same way
what's the Russian doll - cosmonaut dog
oh [ __ ] nun pop it up the same way
out of the duck same way like how we
fought in the last one we saw Adam world
walks cocooned out the end of this year
I was it we flat out know that it was
Adam somebody better beat him it just
feels like he's got a paints with fan
brush so you know he's like oh my god if
you got to do like you know they did a
sequence that Instagram Facebook and
sequence where they're bouncing through
different right after again in the bar
together they're jumping through the
wormholes and Anakin could have like you
know less than an alleged filmmaker
myself and has done like two of those we
can't have gone and stuff and that's
what gets you to like moments like oh
[ __ ] it's for Watchers okay playful
things like that that's you know I'll
take that guy keep him in the [ __ ]
Marvel Universe they've already
announced
Royal three three so will he be the
first Marvel filmmaker that does his own
trilogy the holy [ __ ] to nuts
yeah because Favreau did wanted to
environment then get to do to me we need
and want Avengers does not get to do
new ones yeah John solder Johnston did
Captain America first Avengers didn't
get eggs other - so James not made being
the first becomes a little director -
I'm going to finish my trilogy and
hopefully it's not a trilogy and
hopefully they let them just fun yeah
keep going
because they're charming characters done
and handled insanely well so anybody we
left out so she could love - mmm mmm I
don't think so
I mean I think I miss the Nova cool it's
an EF in love no core lesson and john c
reilly exact like that yes and then the
Peter Serafinowicz guy who was the lead
pilot I was like what a bunch of arrows
I love like there they did tell one line
though did you get out my money's like
you know when they're gone - he goes
planet and I think the Moors like you're
half cheering never one beer because I
was sitting there watching the movie
going like I wonder if the longer gunner
and he showed no one to stir I love the
opening sequence they open I'm like like
that bad in the yondu killer Space Pen
one of my two favorite visual sequences
like there's poetry and both of them you
talking about the Beast coming to get
the battery and so them at the flashback
to improve no I might like to see I'm
like that but I'll be you talking about
that's just a baby group foreground also
having ended up in the backround yeah
very cool idea but I liked it and
execution was not as excuse elevated but
I preferred the simplicity of the
opening of the last one with him by
himself
mmm it wasn't unexpected right like you
know it starts in a very starts very
emotionally and also we're in space
26 years later it's very Raiders of the
Lost Ark in space and also he pulls out
the [ __ ] Walker and straining mind
come get your book and you know you're
like oh [ __ ] where are we this felt like
that opening sequence felt like alright
they love that man there's maybe group
they like when chalk in Jack's condom so
we'll do that it was basically a
greatest hits of the last movie yeah
before during the credits which is like
fine you want to give me a movie and
it's entertaining because they had
dancing baby Groot more drown stuff does
you want give me four five minutes ah
time
court that being said I preferred Chris
Pratt Dan by himself well this doesn't
accuse me because that's saying that the
Chris Pratt dancing myself plants such a
stake in just here's what this movie is
totally here's what you're going to get
it's gonna be funny simply pop culture
it's going to be like throwback 70 tunes
it dudes gonna be dancing an alien [ __ ]
like it it's setting the tone it's such
a brazen [ __ ] way right at this point
we know the tone yeah so now we're just
having fun and now it sounds like I'm
going to show you something you've never
seen before which one really cool ideas
like you're gonna that action sequence
yes no yes every other movie would
invest all of your attention in for ten
minutes you're going to show you this
guy this plant dancing is what we're
here for is playing I wish they could
keep them as babies grew forever that
looks like they're gonna hold them up
again I mean teenage group yeah because
like really gross the [ __ ] branches
everywhere
once again Marvel has done it like run
out spend your [ __ ] money this is
what movies are all about when old
timers like guys go like Oh back when we
were kids
Raiders the Lost Ark and something Star
Wars polka Superman we're in that Golden
Age right now because this movie a stand
shoulder to shoulder with and he was as
far as I'm concerned terms of sheer joy
that I had sitting in a movie theater
letting it wash all over me I'll be
honest literally thought about going to
see it one more time before we did this
review at 9:30 this morning but I only
like to see it I like eight o'clock I
was so [ __ ] hit the scene so hard to
see really so I get there this is good
sound braggy but i don't know so
straight so I only messed kosher do it I
get there and you know it's like five
minutes too late and seven for Pancho so
look [ __ ] I'll go to some thirty without
my car [ __ ] blaze and then go watch
the moving [ __ ] even better
okay I'm playing on that free weed all
the same so those men out of the car Bob
pick a lot of people obviously catch
them to see this movie and clearly
you'll be there similar interests so
there was a lot of hay
these pictures let's say think she's and
stuff which is nice I mean even do my
job for you then there are these two
kids who taking a picture
they're like I think you wanted writing
they said yeah they're going some 30
going some three now we're going to
lemon three
and I was like lemons three why are you
here at night and like yeah while I'm
very like now we just bought the wrong
ticket and I was like you guys want to
go earlier and they're like yeah all
right let's go in and saw bottom ticket
so you got some toys and take your 11:30
you know Pat was ecology didn't pay it
forward Kevin Spacey that should be bad
for them it just felt weird there's
enough to sit around for four [ __ ]
hours outside the preciate or we're all
having a good time but that's how like
in fees there was I was like well that
just sort of make me tickets for all it
makes me thanks for to makes me hearken
back to those glory days as a kid when
you actually had to wait on line for a
movie yeah I didn't have to do that in a
while
not me here take me oh yeah I mean be I
can pick my own seat alleviates the
desire to have to do that but I have
super fun memories of like in 1992
waiting for hours to get into the first
showing in Jurassic Park or Terminator 2
or the fugitive or whatever it was like
I'm just we're all here guys glad look
at here I like the line in theory but
not in practice I want to argue why last
night we started these shows like it
might as well been Friday [ __ ] night
this but I got a preview was like seven
o'clock there's a show 7:15 7:30 7:45
Nate o'clock baby line them up like
[ __ ] jets and a few of them were 3d
and [ __ ] I want to be doodle doesn't
really nice um there it is man go out
and support this kind of thing on
moviemaking not regarded the galaxy yeah
they regarded left on the left guard to
the right arm he's right whoa Wow
well done there it is Falls for Batman
I'm Batman Kevin snow monkey North come
back to see us next episode saying that
I'm saying that channels markets calm or
youtube.com slash Kim Smith
felony candy bar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you